>>Ian Ni-Lewis: Hey.
>>Dan Galpin: [laughs] That was good.
You tried not to scare me that time.
[laughs]
>>Ni-Lewis: Welcome to the Friday Review of
Games.
As always, I am Ian Ni-Lewis.
>>Galpin: And I'm Dan Galpin.
>>Ni-Lewis: Joining us today is the Widmer
Brothers' Pitch Black IPA.
It's like IPA for Batman.
>>Galpin: I like that.
Since the Dark Knight Returns is now premiering
in lots of other places in the world other
than the United States, it makes sense for
us to have a Batman brew, right?
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
Because we wouldn't want to just stick to
the US and ignore the rest of the world.
>>Galpin: That's not--
>>Ni-Lewis: That wouldn't be our way at all.
>>Galpin: That is not the Google way.
>>Ni-Lewis: By the way, I have to also mention
that Mountain Dew really let me down.
They used to have Pitch Black Mountain Dew,
which was black.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: It was great.
But then they did a Batman tie-in, and I guess
they just figured they couldn't reuse it,
or whatever.
>>Galpin: Right, exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: So what do they come up with?
Dark Berry.
>>Galpin: Dark-- ugh. [shudders]
>>Galpin: I know!
It's like a batsuit with nipples on it.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right?
>>Galpin: Mmhmm.
I know exactly what you're talking about.
All right.
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
Let's get to the games.
We are looking at Tower Defense games.
>>Galpin: That means we have a lot of games
to look at--
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh yeah.
>>Galpin: --because there are a lot of fantastically
good Tower Defense games on Google Play.
Ian has played almost all of them.
>>Ni-Lewis: But Dan's played them more recently
because yesterday while he was playing games,
I was celebrating my birthday.
>>Galpin: Yeah, absolutely.
Happy birthday, Ian.
And actually, I wanted to apologize to all
of the Android Camp participants this year,
because while they were doing their final
project presentations, I was playing video
games in order to prepare for this show.
>>Ni-Lewis: Especially that one dude in the
back that I never learned his name, but he
said he watches our show.
Hey dude!
How's it going?
All right.
>>Galpin: [laughs] All right.
Yes, it's a dude from Sri Lanka who goes to
University of Toronto.
How does that sound?
Is that close enough?
All right.
>>Ni-Lewis: We can track him down.
Watch out.
>>Galpin: That's right.
>>Ni-Lewis: Okay, so Tower Defense games,
if you watched my review of Radiant Defense
a couple weeks ago, you'll know that they're
one of my favorite genres.
I don't know why.
I think it's partly the strategy, it's partly
the fact that I can pick them up and put them
down really easily.
I don't need great reflexes for most Tower
Defense games, which is good.
>>Galpin: Yeah, if you're drinking, for example,
right?
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, or if you've ever seen my
production of Reto Meier's app review, you
know that my reflexes are not the canniest
in the world.
>>Galpin: [laughs] Move to the tablet!
Move to the tablet! [laughs]
>>Ni-Lewis: Damn it!
When we looked for Tower Defense games, I
was hoping that I'd see some new ones.
We actually saw a lot that we'd looked at
before, but there were a couple that were
brand new.
>>Galpin: There were.
>>Ni-Lewis: I think that's very cool.
What are we going to look at first?
Let's get the junk out of the way first.
Well, junk is a harsh term.
There were some nominations that we're going
to go ahead and reject, because they're not
really Tower Defense games.
>>Galpin: There are so many schemes that are
specific in this genre that are--.
To have a game that's really not a Tower Defense
game but just has towers in it is definitely
something that we don't need.
>>Ni-Lewis: Cartoon Wars, for instance, which
is not a Tower Defense game, but a game in
which you defend a tower.
>>Galpin: By the way, this is--.
Actually, let's bring up something.
Let's bring up the tablet.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, Reto, why don't you show
us what's going on.
>>Galpin: We don't currently have network.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, Reto, can you show us the
tablet please?
>>Galpin: [laughs] When you don't have a network,
you can't play the game.
It just pops up a dialog.
>>Ni-Lewis: That's unfortunate.
>>Galpin: This is so sad.
There are a lot of games that do this, if
they require a network.
It's so jarring.
One, I'd like to, – I don't think there's
any strong reason why this game can't be played
offline.
But two, if you're going to do this, make
it feel like it's actually part of the game,
not like this giant error happens.
It's not a great user experience.
There are potentially things you might want
to be able to see within the game.
>>Ni-Lewis: I'm a little confused, actually.
I've played this game.
It's not a bad game.
It's not a Tower Defense game.
It's more of a one dimensional.
What would you call this?
There was the Army of Darkness, uh, Gladiator.
>>Galpin: Yeah, it's a different genre.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, it's a 'buy dudes and send
them to the right' game.
>>Galpin: It's sort of a resource management,
battlefield simulation, almost.
It's like you have to--.
There is a strategy, but you're not placing
towers, you're just like, "Ahh!" and your
guys--
>>Ni-Lewis: Anyway, the point I was trying
to make without getting too long winded is
I've played this game.
I don't see any reason that it has to be connected
to a network.
A lot of people don't have reliable network
service.
We don't because we're in the middle of the
Android building where people feel completely
free to just use all of the available air
space for random test projects--
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
>>Ni-Lewis: --that block our WiFi.
>>Galpin: You do have to realize when you
have several thousand devices on the WiFi
in a building, it's going to stress things
out.
I think, actually, this device has just lost
WiFi due to, probably, some sort of issue.
I don't, oh, it's in airplane mode.
Haha!
Never mind.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, well, there you go.
But that brings to mind my other point, which
is, "Hey!
You know where I love to play games?
On airplanes!"
It's true that not everybody travels as much
as your typical Googler.
>>Galpin: We're good here.
We're not even going to look at Cartoon Wars,
because it's not a Tower Defense game.
We wanted to mention that.
I wanted to mention that I actually like playing
games offline.
I did go and test that.
And let's get into the actual Tower Defense
games themselves.
Now, we're going to go pretty quickly through
things we've looked at already.
>>Ni-Lewis: Why don't we start with one of
the classics, Fieldrunners?
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
Just to display.
Now, I'm not sure we have a title card for
this one, Reto.
We might not.
So we're just going to have to go to a non
title card equipped display.
There we are.
Fieldrunners is one of--.
There's a couple of variations in the genre.
Fieldrunners is the variation where you get
to, where you have guys running from one side
to the other, and you actually get to change
their course by putting down towers.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
It's an open field with path defined by towers.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
And the key strategy element is the characters
will always take the shortest path from one
side to the other.
Your goal is to make their path long.
Then, just when you think you've gotten this
all taken care of, you'll realize that people
actually will fly in the shortest path over
and will ignore all of your defenses.
Ultimately, you have to make some decisions,
whether you're going to continue to build
towers in the most logical, crazy pattern,
or whether you're going to build towers that
will hit planes.
>>Ni-Lewis: Let's contrast that with--.
Oh, by the way, let's contrast that with another
Tower Defense game that's been quite popular.
It's also a very good game.
But it takes a completely different approach,
where everything is constrained.
Both the location of the towers and the path
that people are going to follow.
This game is a beautiful game.
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
Actually, it's interesting, because this game
involves levels that have a significant amount
of craft in the levels.
Because the goal of the level is to provide
a puzzle for which towers you place where.
They limit the number of options.
So in a sense, this game has a little more
of a different kind of a variation.
The design of the levels is actually more
critical than the design of the individual
element.
A lot of times, they'll throw new players
at you in order to change the game up a lot,
or new enemies.
This game actually does both.
It throws completely different levels and
completely different enemies, and you have
to use different strategies based upon the
different places you're actually allowed to
place towers.
But it's not as open ended.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
I agree.
It's more of a puzzle type of atmosphere.
It doesn't feel like I'm playing a strategy
game.
It feels like I'm trying to figure out what
the correct combination is.
That can be its own set of fun.
Jelly Defense has a fairly typical user interface
where you're dragging towers from some UI
area, in this case, down in the corner, and
then you're placing them on specific points
on the map.
>>Galpin: Yeah, one of the things I actually--.
One of the UI changes is--
>>Ni-Lewis: Do you collect those?
>>Galpin: --you do have to collect them, yeah.
One-- and you see I just completely screwed
this up, because the blue tower doesn't do
anything against the red guys.
>>Ni-Lewis: Ah, yes, that's right.
But you can have a tower that does both red
and blue.
>>Galpin: Yes, exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: It's that one.
>>Galpin: That's actually one of the unique
things about this game, is that they actually
have this concept of towers that are ineffective
against one color or another.
That's not going to probably build fast enough.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, I know.
Yeah, that's another interesting thing, is
that some games will have towers that build
immediately, and some games will have towers
that take a little bit of time.
Another thing that will differentiate these
is when we pause, can we still build towers?
>>Galpin: Exactly.
Some games are real time Tower Defense games.
This one is a true real time Tower Defense
game.
That's the only way it's played.
Now, from a menuing structure, there's really
two styles.
One is where you drag from the corner.
Another one is where you select where you
want to build and--.
By the way, this is one of these things where
if you have icons, sometimes it's tricky to
see just what your icon is actually going
to do at any given point.
So yeah, this is the drag one.
I actually really like the select where you
want to build a tower and get a menu on the
spot, because it's less clicking.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, definitely.
Let's take a look at one that does that.
Com2uS, a large Korean game company, has actually
copyrighted, or trademarked the term Tower
Defense.
Any game that calls itself Tower Defense or
has Tower Defense in the title will actually
get a nice polite letter from their lawyers.
But yeah, Tower Defense has a nice UI to it,
where most of the UI elements are hidden until
you absolutely need them.
Clicking on the screen will actually activate
them.
I do really like that.
>>Galpin: And this game has really nice, high
res, sharp graphics.
It's fun.
The only thing about this particular game
is this is another one--.
This is a fixed path Tower Defense game.
It's not as limited, in Jelly Defense, in
the sense that you can place towers in lots
and lots of different and varied places.
But the path in which the characters run is
fixed.
But it is really cool just to build towers
willy-nilly like that.
You can see, there's actually--
>>Ni-Lewis: And they build immediately in
this one.
>>Galpin: Yeah, exactly.
There's not nearly as much time, where, you
know, space and no time.
>>Ni-Lewis: I think we've compared and contrasted
some of the styles.
Let's talk about some of the--.
Now, Jelly Defense, I think one of the things
that we saw with it--.
Oh, go ahead.
>>Galpin: I was going to say actually just
one comment.
This game has very, very high resolution background
artwork.
You can actually see that on the icons and
text.
It is a little lower resolution in the screen.
You might not be able to see that on the live
stream, but this is--.
Even in this game, which looks amazing, if
we had a slightly higher resolution font,
it would look a little less blurry.
I would say, that would be my one comment
on the visuals here.
Because otherwise, the game is so high resolution
and so polished.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, all of the tiles are really
high res.
>>Galpin: But again, if you actually polish
the backgrounds without actually making a
higher resolution font, that is going to make
the game look worse.
We see some other games here that have fallen
into that trap as well.
If you're going to spend, strangely enough,
if you're going to spend some extra application
real estate on anything in terms of high resolution,
a font is great.
Especially since you can, for a lot of these
games, take advantage of the fact that we
have really nice open type implementations.
If you can get an outline font that will work,
we do a pretty good job of rendering that
pretty quickly.
That is really the way to go.
You'll see a bunch of games that do use that
as well.
>>Ni-Lewis: This game also has reasonably
good animation.
It's not the best I've ever seen.
There's not depth animation for the enemies.
It has the, it's got the feature where you
can actually call a wave early.
Reto, if you wouldn't mind going to the tablet
now.
[pause] See, not so easy, is it, when you're
on the other side, yeah?
Okay.
If you have an early call button--.
And this is something that you'll see in a
lot of these games, where you'll hit a button
and you can actually send out the waves a
little faster.
Another thing you'll see is being able to--
>>Galpin: Speed up time.
>>Ni-Lewis: --speed up time, yeah.
Because, really, these are the sort of games
where you take relatively few actions, but
you do them very frequently.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
Actually, one of the things I really like
is you can actually see in this game, it actually
shows you as waves are coming through.
This game is good.
My main thing about this game is that it is--
It implements the basics of Tower Defense
incredibly, incredibly well.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Galpin: But, to me, it's not as fun as some
of the other games.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, I thought, it's definitely
got a good selection of towers.
You have some different situations where you
need to use a particular mix of towers.
And I like that.
>>Galpin: Ooh, look at that.
[whispers] Back button now, Ricky.
Bad.
>>Ni-Lewis: But I felt like, I don't know.
I felt like it introduced them a little too
slowly.
I don't know, there's just something about
the game play that wasn't quite as fun.
Some of the maps were maybe a little too hard
to begin with.
>>Galpin: By the way, the back key really
is not working here.
>>Ni-Lewis: No, the back key isn't working.
That's a real problem.
Other than that, most of these things--
>>Galpin: Also, the ads were kinda funny.
Sometimes they do come up full screen, but
when you're putting, especially your own ads,
on a tablet, you know that.
That's another thing, is some of the menus,
I wanted to see a little bit larger when I
was on the tablet, in terms of scale.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, you can definitely use a
little bit more testing on large devices.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
But overall, the game looks good.
>>Ni-Lewis: It really does.
>>Galpin: It's a beautiful game.
>>Ni-Lewis: I just wanted to contrast Jelly
Defense really quickly.
There's nothing wrong with what they've done
here, but it's a little more obvious that
they've poured it from a 4:3 build and gone
16:9.
Now, we would always prefer that you actually
just do a 16:9 build.
That's always going to look better.
But, in this case, at least they haven't just
squished everything and letterboxed the whole
thing, or pillarboxed the whole thing.
They've got a nice set of UI around here.
Ooh, it's got little trails that follow my
finger.
>>Galpin: Trails, yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: That's so sweet.
>>Galpin: Yeah, this game is really a work
of art.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, it really is nice.
>>Galpin: I really do wish, though, just honestly,
all they need is a little bit of extra graphic
on the side that's not interacted-- that we're
interacting with, and it would be just so
beautiful and so perfect.
>>Ni-Lewis: That really is all you need.
Just fill those out.
>>Galpin: And again, that's something that
if you design at the beginning, it's very
easy.
If you come into it, we're like "Oh, all of
a sudden, we need lots and lots of new art."
That's hard.
But I really would love to see that for this
game.
That would be the thing that takes it over
the top, as far as I'm concerned.
As I said, it's a little bit of a preference
what style of Tower Defense game you prefer.
I think for people who haven't done a lot
of these games, this is actually really nice.
>>Ni-Lewis: This is a great entry level Tower
Defense.
>>Galpin: It really, really is.
>>Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
Look at the animation.
Look at the care they've done.
All of the transitions are perfect.
All of the game play just has this really
nice look and feel to it where everything's
moving and everything's believable.
Everything looks 3-D.
>>Galpin: And the graphical style is brilliant.
I think, actually, everything, I think a lot
of the elements may actually be 3-D. They
certainly do have a giant 3-D--.
If we go back to the menu here.
I don't want to restart the level, I want
to go--.
This is actually, by the way, one of my complaints
is this is how you get to the menu.
The level selector is that other thing, which
doesn't look like anything.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
Well, it looks like one of those dudes, right?
>>Galpin: It looks like one of those dudes,
which--.
It doesn't look like it means this, but actually,
this is the level selector here, which is
a nice--
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, it kinda looks like that guy.
>>Galpin: It kinda looks like that guy, yeah.
This is a nice 3-D element and is cool.
You see we're in this incredibly cool space,
this place.
Again, there is, and actually, if we didn't
have HDMI connected, you would see that it's
actually even running a little more smoothly
than it looks here.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
The HDMI removes 10 pounds.
I mean, fps.
>>Galpin: Yeah, it does hurt the frame rate
a little.
But yeah.
This is a beautifully, beautifully done game.
>>Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
>>Galpin: It's got feet!
>>Ni-Lewis: That's cute.
>>Galpin: All right, let's go back.
Let's go look at another one.
We want to cover something a little different.
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, why don't we take a look
at Sentinel 3.
>>Galpin: Sentinel 3 or the Space Station,
which one?
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, let's start with Sentinel
3, because I want to contrast the Space Station.
Sentinel 3, when I was on parental leave last
year, I spent almost every waking moment that
I could playing Sentinel 3.
I love this game.
There's a couple things that I really loved
about it.
The first is it's a-- It is a fixed path Tower
Defense game, but there are multiple paths
that enemies will come down.
But its more interesting feature is that it
has an avatar system where, in addition to
building towers, you also control this guy
in a suit of Mecca Armor that has special
powers, special abilities.
>>Galpin: Yeah, it's awesome.
It adds a really great twist.
The art style is beautiful.
This is just--
>>Ni-Lewis: It reminds me a lot of the games
like Starcraft or something like those.
Really well done.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
This is a gorgeous, gorgeous game.
Especially--
>>Ni-Lewis: Especially if you download the
HD pack.
Did you?
You did, right?
>>Galpin: Yes, I downloaded the HD pack.
That's the thing I was going to say.
What's also nice about this game is that it
actually comes with an SD pack that runs pretty
much everywhere.
And then, with just a little bit of--.
Let me actually place some towers here [laughs]
so we don't die.
>>Ni-Lewis: Now this, again, is the drag and
drop method of Tower.
I'm not a big fan.
There's a few things about this interface
that make it a little bit difficult.
I think that first, the fact that you have
to drag and drop is annoying, but fine.
The fact, though, that the UI actually sits
over areas of the map that, not in this map,
but in other maps, are actually playable--.
So you see the pause and the fast forward
button here.
Those will actually cover areas of the map
where you have to place towers.
To me, that's unacceptable because it means
that I have to do a lot of map navigation
that's just in-- for the sole purpose of keeping
the UI from getting in my way.
[pause] Going with the philosophy that you
should always be fighting the enemies in the
game and not fighting the UI, I think this
one fails just a little bit.
Now, we actually talked to the developers
about that, and they were looking into some
ways to fix it.
They certainly helped some.
I think there used to be a big OpenFeint button
here.
And nothing against OpenFeint.
The problem, though, was that if you press
that button, it would start an OpenFeint cycle
that took about 20 seconds, and you couldn't
get out of it.
>>Galpin: Yeah, yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: It's very, very easy to press
those by accident, because, you can see, if
I wanted to place a tower up here--.
Well, what am I trying to do there?
Am I trying to place the tower or click the
settings?
What's it going to decide?
It decided--
>>Galpin: I was trying to--
>>Ni-Lewis: --both, actually.
>>Galpin: Did you place a tower, too?
>>Ni-Lewis: Yes, it did.
There's a tower there, see?
I'll show you because you have to zoom in.
There it is.
>>Galpin: Oh yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: And see, if I want to upgrade
the tower--.
Now, the upgrade, you click on the tower and
hit the upgrade button.
You can see that that tower is almost impossible
to upgrade without doing--
>>Galpin: A zoom and a manipulation.
>>Ni-Lewis: --a zoom.
It's one of those things where if they just
limited the playable areas a little bit.
>>Galpin: Mmhmm.
Now, it does help that there's only two buttons.
But actually, to be honest, there's no, I
would actually say that you could actually,
the fast forward button is nice to have.
That's have there.
Whether you need both is--
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, well, no, no.
The fast forward button is fine.
The pause button is actually really important
because in this game--
>>Galpin: Yes.
No, absolutely.
>>Ni-Lewis: --you want to be able to pause.
But put it in an area where you're not going
to have a lot of game play.
One of the major problems of this game is
that there are maps where the first choke
point is underneath one of these buttons.
All of the initial action is confined to just
a corner of the screen.
If you're just in a corner of the screen and
there's buttons in the way, it can be immensely
frustrating.
>>Galpin: Mmhmm.
Absolutely.
>>Ni-Lewis: There's a couple of other things
that are interesting.
You've got the avatar.
You've also got these gates that he defends.
You get bonus points if the gates don't fall,
but the level doesn't end if the gate falls.
So you actually have several different things
that you're defending, and not just your ultimate
base.
You also have the ability to collect resources
in later levels, although I felt that was
balanced a little poorly, because I could
never get to the point where resource collection
was actually paying for itself.
>>Galpin: Also, one thing that's interesting
is that it is by placing towers, in this case
close to my main sentinel, that actually makes
them more powerful.
That's what that little circle there means.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
As your sentinel gains levels, that circle
actually gets bigger.
You have this--.
And of course, that affects your strategy
later on when there's multiple gates that
enemies could be coming through, because what
you'll do is you'll [clears throat] you'll
send your sentinel over to one gate, and then
another one starts getting attacked so you
jump over there.
You really need to pay attention to where
that guy is.
>>Galpin: Yeah, it adds a lot of RPG--.
RPG elements in these kinds of games are cool.
I think that's--.
This game mashes it up a little, even though
at its basis, it is what we call fixed path,
which is one of the simpler kinds of these
games.
I'm actually kinda sad because one of the
games that I played a lot was Guns'n'Glory.
That's a very similar kind of game.
>>Ni-Lewis: That's a fixed path game, right?
>>Galpin: It's a fixed path game as well,
so I was kinda sad that it didn't get nominated.
>>Ni-Lewis: Why didn't you nominate it?
>>Galpin: Well, I should have, but I was--.
There were so many nominations already that
were good, I decided we'd just stick with
the ones that we had.
>>Ni-Lewis: Ah, that's a good point.
By the way, thank you very much.
We were really excited to see so many nominations
in this category.
It's really exciting when we can find games
that we haven't seen before.
We feel like we're really unearthing some
diamonds in the rough by getting you guys
involved.
We really appreciate that.
With that in mind, why don't we take a look
at one of the games that we haven't seen before?
>>Galpin: Looked at before.
All right.
There's a couple of interesting ones here.
What we've looked at on the show versus what
we've looked at elsewhere, which--.
Why don't you pick one of these, since I know
that, I've looked at all of them.
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, do you have a Knight--?
Yeah.
I hadn't seen A Knight's Dawn at all.
>>Galpin: It's a Unity game.
You can tell because it's actually using an
older version of Unity.
Oh, wait!
Did this game?
I wonder if I ever did--
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh no.
>>Galpin: This game might actually crash.
I can't remember whether I got this game to
work now that I'm thinking about it.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, okay.
We'll totally take a look at that later.
>>Galpin: We'll take a look at that later.
That was the one game that I hadn't had a
chance to look at, now that, because it crashed.
>>Ni-Lewis: Wow, I sure can pick 'em.
How about Myth Defense?
>>Galpin: [laughs] The fact that it had that
Unity splash team means that they're using
a really, really old version of Unity.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
So they need to update.
>>Galpin: They do need to update that.
>>Ni-Lewis: Myth is pretty.
>>Galpin: Myth Defense is beautiful.
I was really, really glad to see that.
Do we have a title card for this one or not?
Yeah, this is one of the ones that's beyond
the first ten--
>>Ni-Lewis: I think we had title cards for
the first ten.
We should probably spend very little time
on this.
>>Galpin: Yeah, exactly.
But this game, actually, I really, really
like.
I'm glad we got to mention it.
It is definitely in the non fixed path style
of Tower Defense games.
But I really like the fact that it's using
this particular theme.
You see I was able to just continue back from
where I left off.
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, almost.
You had a game in progress, but it still made
you go through all those menus to begin with.
That's kinda annoying.
>>Galpin: It's true.
It's true.
But actually, if I close, I think I actually
didn't fully close the game.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, okay.
So if I just hit home, what's going to happen?
>>Galpin: Let's try it.
Let's find out.
This is a really good question.
Restoring.
So, I'm right there.
I'm just going to have to hit play in order
to continue.
That's, it did the right thing there.
I think the fact that the game did completely
close.
Now, whether or not--.
The only thing I don't remember is whether
I hit the home screen.
I think I did "exit the game" before.
Legitimately.
I was testing what happens when the back key
was pressed.
I think the artwork is really pretty.
The style is fun.
It is, again, this is the most traditional,
I'd say, of these kinds of games.
>>Ni-Lewis: I think we're always really impressed
when someone takes the time to really do a
good job at these high resolution displays.
Remember, this is an ASUS EEE Transformer
Prime.
This is by far not the highest resolution
display that's going to be on the market this
year.
I think I've already talked about at least
one 10 ADP display.
But you can tell that the crispness of these
graphics, especially if we zoom in a little
bit-- on these graphics, Reto-- you'll see
that each one of the graphics, from the towers
to the UI, is really, really detailed.
It's not just high res, it's detailed high
res.
Look at those cobblestones.
Look at the detail on those towers.
Look at the vegetation.
It's amazing.
It's really, really well done.
That's impressive to me.
>>Galpin: Yeah, absolutely.
The other thing I would say about this one
is that if you've looked at this game, you've
looked at the Com2uS' Tower Defense game side
by side, if you look at the tiles in the background,
they look relatively similarly detailed, but
if you look at the fonts here, the fonts here
are really sharp, really high res.
That makes a huge difference.
They are also rendered in a style that looks
semi 3D.
It just adds--
>>Ni-Lewis: You get a little bit of a drop
shadow.
>>Galpin: Yeah, a little bit of a drop shadow.
>>Ni-Lewis: That's nice.
>>Galpin: They've also got a little bit of
a gradient on them.
It just looks really pro.
They did a really nice job with this.
Again, I haven't played the game long enough
to be able to give a full, in depth review,
but I like what I've seen so far.
>>Ni-Lewis: You can see, by the way, that
this is not a full 16:9 playing surface.
It's not 4:3 either.
It's interesting.
I'm not sure where that came from.
But-- Or, maybe it was 4:3 and they've just
chosen to do it this way, right?
Can you zoom?
>>Galpin: No.
>>Ni-Lewis: No, okay.
That's interesting.
What you can see is they've done a little
bit of fill on the edges.
By doing a tiny bit of fill on the edges,
they've made something that, I think, actually
works on both a 4:3 and a 16:9 just as easily.
It looks great!
It looks intentional on both resolutions instead
of looking like it's been ported from one
or the other.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
What they did, putting this little border
on the side here in order to get some additional
real estate, makes a huge difference, rather
than having black bars.
Sometimes, even a little thing like that makes
a huge difference.
>>Ni-Lewis: And again, notice that the borders
are not just borders.
They've also moved the UI into those areas
so that it's not wasted space.
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
>>Ni-Lewis: Which is great, because the more
UI on the playing field, the more irritating
the game will get, honestly.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
It's great to be able to get that stuff out
of the way.
They really do a good job with that.
So yeah, in general, this is a model.
If you don't actually want to go deeper and
create--.
What would even be nicer is if they extended
this border all the way out, and it didn't
look like there was this hard ledge here on
the sides.
But if you can't do that, this is the next
best thing.
Honestly, it really makes a huge difference.
It may not seem like it, but if we just saw
black bars here, it would feel wrong.
It would feel like we were watching an experience.
Just less.
>>Ni-Lewis: It would.
It would.
If you've got a solid color, that's even worse.
This is something that developers should understand,
that this year, [pause] Google, as you can
see with the launch of the Nexus 7, were very,
very serious about Android tablets.
We've talked to the Play team, and they've
said to us many times that they are going
to stop, as much as possible, stop featuring
games that don't have good tablet support.
There are--.
Some apps and some games just don't, they're
not a natural tablet fit.
>>Galpin: Honestly, almost any game is going
to play better on something like a Nexus 7
than it's going to play on most phones.
>>Ni-Lewis: And remember, too, that tablet
owners tend to buy about four times as many
games as phone owners.
>>Galpin: Yeah, per owner.
>>Ni-Lewis: Per owner, yeah.
>>Galpin: People look at them as consumption
devices.
People buy a lot of phones, they use it as
a phone, they use it for their Gmail.
A lot of people who buy tablets do think of
it as a primary game device as well as another
consumption device.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, if you're doing another
Bubble Breaker that's just going to help somebody
to waste time while they're waiting for the
bus, maybe you can get by with the phone version.
But if you're doing a great detailed game
like this, you should absolutely be planning
for Android tablets of all shapes and sizes.
>>Galpin: Let's take--.
Speaking of tablets, let's go to a completely
different kind of game.
This is Orc Genocide.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, nice.
Ooh.
And it's--
>>Galpin: You can actually play this head
to head over a LAN.
It is portrait.
Let's play against the CPU.
We'll play against the green CPU here.
You'll see that it actually is a game that's
set up for two people to play against each
other, by default.
I've got some things here.
I can actually start placing my towers.
This is, again, a very different style of
game.
I was even debating whether we would call
this a true Tower Defense game.
There's also a couple of options here.
I can actually start upgrading my characters
that are going to be produced here.
>>Ni-Lewis: So are you producing mobile characters,
or are you just putting down towers?
>>Galpin: I'm putting down towers which are
going to produce tanks or footmen.
This is sort of, I would say it's, each one
of these guys are going to produce little
characters that are ultimately going to do
my battling for me.
The towers aren't actually, aren't necessarily
fighting themselves, although sometimes they
are.
But they're also producing characters.
>>Ni-Lewis: Interesting.
Sort of a cross between a Tower Defense and
something more like Cartoon Wars.
>>Galpin: Yes, yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: Interesting.
The graphics.
Really ugly.
I say that advisedly.
Do you think it's an homage?
It feels like I'm playing a Commodore 64.
Is that intentional?
>>Galpin: You know, I think that there's a
lot of low res graphics intentionally on this,
but I also do feel that it's this weird combination
of both.
>>Ni-Lewis: I do see that sword that looks
kinda high res.
Do you think maybe they're just stretched
on this display?
>>Galpin: I don't think so.
I think that the idea is the little orcs are
APIC throwbacks--
>>Ni-Lewis: Okay.
>>Galpin: --and that the other graphics are
intended to be high res.
Unfortunately, because the resolution of this
tablet is very high, a lot of them just look
really, really low res.
>>Ni-Lewis: I see.
>>Galpin: But I really like the idea of head
to head combat.
It makes so much sense with this tablet, form
factor.
I can't wait to see where they would go with
this.
It seems like there's a lot of potential here.
I'm not sure about all of the strategy, but
you can build towers in all sorts of different
places.
You see they get attacked from all sides,
now.
You can drop, I just got killed by the CPU
on the lowest levels, so I clearly didn't
do a very good job at this game.
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, you are playing sideways.
>>Galpin: I am playing sideways.
That's mostly to keep the cable from getting
pulled out--
>>Ni-Lewis: That's true.
>>Galpin: --so you guys can see what's going
on.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, we need some cable glue
or something.
>>Galpin: [laughs] Exactly.
Some duct tape would work, I think.
Yes, that's pretty much all I wanted to say
there.
As far as the game itself, obviously there
are resolution issues in Orc Genocide.
I'm not, I didn't get to try the WLAN version,
but split screen is kinda awesome.
This is where it really shines, on a tablet.
This is why I want to see them upgrade their
graphics.
We can now--
>>Ni-Lewis: We can play together here.
>>Galpin: Yeah, exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: Nice.
>>Galpin: I can summon towers, you can summon
towers.
Again, we can start sending guys out.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, do I have to explicitly send
guys out, or do they just kinda happen?
>>Galpin: They just happen if you summon the
right kind of buildings.
>>Ni-Lewis: Okay, apparently I am totally
not summoning the right kind of anything because
I'm just getting my ass kicked here.
>>Galpin: [hums]
>>Ni-Lewis: Whatever, dude.
>>Galpin: [laughs] Well, you know.
It is your first time playing.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, what'd I do wrong here?
>>Galpin: You summoned defense buildings,
but you didn't summon them where I've summoned--.
You have to summon them actually in front
of where I summoned my--
>>Ni-Lewis: Attack buildings?
>>Galpin: --attack buildings.
>>Ni-Lewis: Sure, sure, sure.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
Okay, well, lesson learned.
Next game!
>>Galpin: [laughs] Let's go on to--.
Let's see.
>>Ni-Lewis: Let's get back into the top ten.
Well, Orc Genocide was in there, right?
We had the--
>>Galpin: Yes, Orc Genocide was in the top
ten.
>>Ni-Lewis: That's right.
Did we have a title card for that, Reto?
>>Reto Meier: We absolutely did.
>>Galpin: Awesome.
>>Ni-Lewis: Did we use it?
>>Meier: We did.
While I've got you guys, actually, we have
a couple of questions on the YouTube stream
and on the event stream.
I thought I'd throw them out to you.
>>Ni-Lewis: Awesome!!!
>>Galpin: All right.
Cool.
>>Meier: They're fairly straightforward.
Let's see.
On YouTube, who'd like to know "Is it easy
to make apps and games if a person doesn't
know anything about it?
Can they still do it, or do they have to study
coding or something?
>>Ni-Lewis: Okay, hang on.
First, turn your producer cam on, Reto.
I think the world wants to see you.
>>Meier: We can probably do that.
>>Galpin: It is pretty dark over there, though.
>>Ni-Lewis: Just use the Hangout thing.
Oh no, it's just Reto surrounded by a halo
of light, as always.
>>Galpin: Oh, okay.
>>Meier: Fine.
>>Galpin: There we are.
>>Ni-Lewis: It gets a little bit annoying
sometimes.
>>Galpin: [laughs]
>>Ni-Lewis: The answer to that is, can you
make a game--
>>Galpin: I'm covered up.
I like this.
Go on.
>>Ni-Lewis: [laughs] There is another shot
that won't cover Dan's face
>>Galpin: Hold on, let me see.
Now I can pretend that if Reto looks at the
camera, now he can pretend to be me, and we
put the hat on.
There we are.
>>Ni-Lewis: So I think, I've been in video
games for almost 20 years now.
I think it's a really good question: can you
make a video game without knowing coding.
Well, [pause] no.
No, you really can't.
>>Galpin: Yeah, you can't--
>>Ni-Lewis: I mean, there are some tools that
will allow you to try and put together a game,
but eventually it boils down to some form
of coding, whether it's typing in a language
like C- Sharp or C++ or Java, or whether it's
connecting bricks together in some sort of
a game maker environment.
You are going to be writing computer instructions.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
There's certain kinds of tools that allow
you to build really cookie cutter games that
are very, very similar.
But even for a Tower Defense game, you want
to know things like pathing.
You want to make sure that those guys are
always following the shortest path.
That requires a little bit of code.
You might want to have some AI in a lot of
other kinds of games.
Even if you have a system that gives you a
lot of stuff for free like that, you're still
going to want to code.
That being said, there are really great tools
out there that do a lot of work for you.
Honestly, I'm a firm believer that anyone
with the drive can learn how to code.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, I'm not.
>>Galpin: Okay.
>>Ni-Lewis: Because I used to teach coding.
I used to teach computer science.
>>Galpin: [laughs] Right.
>>Ni-Lewis: The truth is, if coding frustrates
you and you really don't get it, my experience
is you probably won't get it--
>>Galpin: --are more than likely not
>>Ni-Lewis: --because the people that I saw
be really successful in my classes, it clicked
with them fairly early on.
>>Galpin: Well, and there's also a difference
between, I think my experience with coding
classwork versus coding in, one of the people
I went to school with who was terrible at
coding classwork became one of the most sex--
successful engineers I know building tools.
>>Ni-Lewis: One of the most sexual engineers
you know?
Yes!
>>Galpin: Successful engineers I know building
tools.
>>Meier: Wait, where's the red button here?
>>Ni-Lewis: [laughs]
>>Galpin: Yeah.
I would say that mostly, to me, it's all,
at least, a lot of the coding is really just
about--
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
And let's also make a distinction, too.
If you want to build a game all by yourself,
then yeah, you might be, you might end up
with one of these tools that help you to make
a cookie cutter game, but there's nothing
really super special about it.
But there are so many things that you can
do with a game that don't involve coding.
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
>>Ni-Lewis: And I think that you would find
that there are far more frustrated coders
out there with decent game engine ideas and
interesting ideas about game design who don't
have someone that can produce art or animation
or music.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: Or even polished level design.
So if you've got talents for games, and you
can share, if you know how to use Blender
or MIAP, or if you know how to use Photoshop,
if you know how to write music.
All of these skills are in incredible demand.
There's lots of people out there that would
love to help you code.
>>Galpin: There's great modding tools out
there.
That's one thing you might want to start playing
with, is one of the existing titles that has
really, really great tools that allow you
to modify the levels.
>>Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
Look at, Bethesda's games always ship with
great modding tools.
I've gotten to the point where I haven't even
finished Skyrim.
I just like playing with the mods.
Absolutely.
There's some incredible--.
And it really enriches and enhances the games.
We have a lot of games to get through here.
Is there another question?
>>Galpin: Do we have another question?
>>Meier: Yeah, one more question, which is
"You mentioned that the Play team reviews
several times in your shows."
They're curious to know, "Is there a way to
figure out if your app has already been reviewed?
It would be nice to have this info, even if
the app is ultimately rejected."
And the specific reasons.
>>Ni-Lewis: That's a good question.
We have that data.
If you ping us, we can tell you.
We generally-- [pause] When we suggest apps
and they get rejected, we generally don't
contact the developer unless they got rejected
for a reason that's easy to fix.
But if you're curious, yeah.
Drop me an email, tell me what game it is,
and I'll look it up for you.
We might consider making that information
public, but as with all internal information,
making it public involves jumping through
a lot of hoops.
>>Galpin: I think it's a really interesting
thing.
I think the best thing is to really give feedback.
I think that if a game is rejected because,
well, it's just never going to featured, it's
not very useful.
If a game is rejected because it has this
or this wrong with it, then the developer
is contacted.
I think the real question is, "Was it looked
at at all?"
A lot of people feel like it goes into a cloud
and they don't know.
I'd love to at least have a way that a developer
could check.
That would cool.
>>Ni-Lewis: That would be great.
Okay, so let's look at a couple--.
Why don't we take a look at Space Station
now?
>>Galpin: Oh, yeah!
This is a cool game.
It does have the button of shame, and it does
have the compatibility mode stuff in it, which
is sad.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, it is very sad, actually.
>>Galpin: What is interesting about it, though,
is that it does actually have both HD and
low resolution graphics, and the graphics
are really different.
I think that's part of the reason why I love
it.
I actually, in some ways, liked the low res
layout, but the HD graphics are really, really
nice.
>>Ni-Lewis: They're very pretty.
I'm very impressed.
The layout isn't quite as creative.
It doesn't have that circle thing.
It's just a little bit, feels a little more
thrown together.
But it's very, very crisp.
Let's go ahead and get into the game.
The interesting thing about this game is that--.
Well, we've talked about open field games
where the enemies' path is determined by the
towers that you build.
We also talked about fixed path games, where
the enemies always follow a single path, no
matter what you build.
This is a little more interesting.
You start with a space station core, and then
you build out from that core.
[pause]
>>Galpin: Yeah, ultimately, the goal is to--
And you have to do two things.
You've got to--.
You see I've got asteroids surrounding me.
I've got to actually build power nodes so
that I can mine the asteroids.
I don't have--
>>Ni-Lewis: Right, so you have a resource
collection issue as well as just a defense
issue.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
The most important thing is to get mining,
but if you obviously mine too much and you
don't actually build defenses, then your miners
will just get destroyed.
So you've got to start building things like
turrets.
And unfortunately, now that I've built miners,
I don't actually have money to build anything
else.
I'm just going to try to collect as much resource
as possible.
I've got incoming destroyers.
I'm going to get killed here.
>>Ni-Lewis: Way to go, dude.
>>Galpin: I'm dead.
>>Ni-Lewis: Where are they coming from?
Where are they coming from?
>>Galpin: I don't know.
Let's see.
>>Ni-Lewis: Over to the left.
>>Galpin: You can zoom in.
You can see them in the top.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, yeah, the top.
>>Galpin: Yeah, you can zoom in.
I'm hosed.
>>Ni-Lewis: Can you build something now?
You got some money!
Can you build something?
>>Galpin: I can't build anything useful.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh my God, yeah, the--
>>Meier: I'm sorry, guys, I'm not sure if
it's from the zoom or something else, but
the video is no longer coming in.
I've got a black screen.
>>Galpin: Oh, hold on.
Let's try it one more time.
One, two, three, let's plug this in.
It is very easy to lose the connection on
this particular micro HDMI.
>>Meier: That's got it.
Thanks.
>>Galpin: There we are.
>>Ni-Lewis: Back to it.
>>Galpin: All right.
Yes.
Building a missile launcher would be super
useful.
I almost have enough money to do that.
Or a rail cannon.
[pause]
>>Ni-Lewis: Almost, almost there!
Okay, missile launcher!
This is cool because most Tower Defense games
will just give you money for enemies killed.
So if you're not killing enemies, you don't
get anything.
Whereas this one, you've got this continuous
thing.
Even between waves of enemies, you're cranking
up the money.
I think that's a cool idea.
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
You'll see now, I have another laser turret.
It takes time to build things.
If I don't build the power nodes, then I cannot
actually build out a laser turret there, because
I only have a limited number of connections,
also.
There is a lot of detail in this game.
And you do need to know where people are coming
from.
So now they're coming from there.
Do I have any defenses out there?
No.
That's where all my miners are.
This is a really serious problem for me now.
I'm going to want to build, oh.
Do I not have a power node to that miner?
That's not good.
I'm getting completely squashed here by these
guys.
>>Ni-Lewis: Ooooh.
Now, how important is the actual topology
of your station?
Or I should say the physical locations of
things, rather than general topology.
>>Galpin: The general topology is more important.
You need to make sure there's enough nodes
connecting things.
Yeah, I'm about to lose the laser turret here,
which is sad.
But at least he'll start firing on that guy.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
This is interesting.
It is more of a hybrid because the, while
we have a lot of elements of Tower Defense
games, it feels like a Tower Defense game,
the enemies behave very differently.
They come in from different directions, they
sit there, and they actually attack your towers,
which is uncommon.
There are some other Tower Defense games.
I think one of the other ones, Towers and
Trolls, I think they will attack your towers.
>>Galpin: Yes.
>>Ni-Lewis: I'm a little, I have mixed feelings
on that, because, especially for Towers and
Trolls, that felt a little gimmicky.
That felt like just, Okay, well, every now
and then, I look and my tower's health is
down.
I need to go fix it with some money.
That's annoying.
Whereas this is like they're attacking my
tower and they're stopping to attack--
>>Galpin: Yes.
>>Ni-Lewis: --so the fact that they're attacking
my tower has some significant impact on the
way that the defense is going to go.
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
The goal is usually you're to survive for
a period of time.
Usually you're waiting for reinforcements
or something like that.
So you may not necessarily defeat these enemies.
Your main space station also has a certain
amount of health.
It's holding off various things for a long
enough period of time.
Let's build one more of these guys.
It's sending an enormous quantity of enemies
at me right now, so.
>>Ni-Lewis: But yeah, I think, in terms of
smoothness, it's a pretty smooth game.
The graphics are pretty good.
I think they could be a little bit higher
resolution.
>>Galpin: Even with the HD--
>>Ni-Lewis: It always bums me out a little
bit when games allow you to zoom in maybe
one or two steps further than they should.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: Essentially, as soon as a pixel
in your art covers more than a pixel on the
screen, that's probably where you ought to
stop.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
I'm about to lose all of my defenses here,
but I only have to survive for another five
seconds.
>>Ni-Lewis: There you go.
>>Galpin: So I may actually make it, despite
everything.
>>Ni-Lewis: You are, yeah.
>>Galpin: Yeah, I see.
>>Ni-Lewis: Victory!
>>Galpin: Even though I got completely obliterated--
>>Ni-Lewis: Pyrrhic victory.
>>Galpin: --I still actually made it through
the level.
>>Ni-Lewis: Awesome.
I think I want to close down with Anomaly
HD.
That is a bit of a genre buster there.
Anomaly puts you sort of on the other side.
It's a Tower Offense game.
A lot of people have tried this.
A lot of people have said, "I'm going to build
a Tower Offense game.
Wouldn't it be interesting if we turned Tower
Defense on its head?"
This is one that I think has succeeded better
than most.
You can see, first, that they've got an extremely
professional looking intro.
Really reminds me of a desktop video game
or a console game.
The UI is very crisp.
The game play is very interesting.
I wouldn't say they've nailed it.
I wouldn't say I feel like this is really
the reverse of a Tower Defense game.
>>Galpin: But it is beautiful.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, it's a beautiful game, and
it's a lot of fun.
Essentially, what you do is you're--.
[pause] You have a convoy of enemies, essentially,
that are going to attack towers.
Or try to get through towers.
[pause] Oh.
Advanced difficulty.
>>Galpin: Oh yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: Feeling frisky today, are we?
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
>>Ni-Lewis: All right, then.
>>Galpin: I'm wearing the Android hat.
I've got the Android Jesus look going.
>>Ni-Lewis: Excellent.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: Or Android Santa.
>>Galpin: Android Santa.
Something like that.
[laughs] All right.
I actually haven't played it on this tablet,
so this is the first time it's run here.
So my apologies, you're getting to see all
of the starting up of the game.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, notice how crisp and smooth
all of that is.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
It's really well done.
And again, I think, again, even here, I can
zoom in and out.
I can pan around.
It's, you know.
I'm now playing, again--.
My goal is, I can change my route here however
I want to get to the target.
I can go like that if I want to.
Obviously, that's not going to help me.
Again, I just--
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, and you can change it in
the middle of the game, too, right?
But that's what this game is about.
It's about planning your route based on where
the towers are.
You do have some offensive weaponry.
You also end up getting power ups through
the game.
Planning the route and determining when to
deploy your power ups is the extent of the
game play.
It ends up being a lot of fun.
When I played it--.
Check that out.
Wow.
That's a great transition, and those are some
beautiful graphics.
When I actually played the game, it held my
attention for a while.
Eventually, I felt like the number of choices
I had in the game play maybe weren't enough
to keep my interest for a long time.
>>Galpin: Mmhmm.
This is--
>>Ni-Lewis: But there are some--.
They do have some interesting twists.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
This is what the strategic part is.
I can deploy a repair icon as well.
Then I tap where I want it to be deployed.
In this case, I want it to be deployed on
top of my guys here.
So boom.
>>Ni-Lewis: Now you can start 'em going.
>>Galpin: Now I can start 'em going.
>>Ni-Lewis: [deep voice] Checkpoint!
>>Galpin: And you see, I've got a certain
amount of repairs.
I've got to use that strategically, also,
in the game.
[pause]
>>Ni-Lewis: [deep voice] Boom!
Look at that.
They've got some smoke, they've got shadows.
>>Galpin: Yeah, there's all sorts of great
things going on here.
Again, this is a game that could have been
done as a 2-D game.
But doing it in 3-D just allows-- Obviously,
I just start from checkpoint.
Yes.
Doing it in 3-D just allows for that much
more awesomeness.
In this case, you can see all these details
are enabled through 3-D.
>>Ni-Lewis: You can drop the repair down there
or something.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: [sneezes] Excuse me.
That's a sneeze.
>>Galpin: Bless you.
All right.
Gesundheit, Gesundheit.
Let's repair a little bit there.
Come on, guys!
I've only got one repair left!
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, and that's really what it
is.
How you deploy the repairs and the other power
ups is--.
And see, in this case, you really haven't
deployed it well.
You need to deploy it so the trailing edge
is there.
But every time you destroy a tower, this airplane
comes by and drops you something cool.
It's a great effect, although I did kinda
get mad at it after a while, because it's
like, "Hey, airplane, why don't you just drop
the stuff I need when I need it?"
>>Galpin: Exactly!
But then the game would be--
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
Video game world logic doesn't always make
sense.
Anyway, we're just about out of time.
But we did want to show you Anomaly War Zone
Earth.
It's a great game.
Really, really impressive graphics.
Like I said, the game play maybe isn't for
everybody.
It's certainly not a Tower Defense game.
But it's an interesting riff of the genre,
so we like it.
Thanks a lot, everyone, for all your Tower
Defense suggestions.
Now, we tried to get through as many suggestions
as we could today.
And, I don't know.
Part of me feels like that was awesome, and
part of me feels like maybe we didn't get
through, or maybe we didn't spend enough time
on each game.
What do you think?
>>Galpin: Well, you know, I will personally
say that I've spent an enormous amount of
time playing these games.
>>Ni-Lewis: No, I meant talking about them
on the show.
>>Galpin: [laughs] I'm kidding.
Yeah, no.
I think that we really gave people a feeling
of the genre.
We got through some of the best games.
Hopefully, there's a few that we didn't get
through.
We will definitely do another segment like
this.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, no question, no question.
>>Galpin: There's so many Tower Defense games
out there.
>>Ni-Lewis: Absolutely.
Let us know what you'd like to see.
Let us know what you think of today's show.
We're very interested to know.
Now, again, the edited version will be up
on YouTube momentarily.
Hopefully tonight.
And next week, we will be back with another
theme, which is driving games.
>>Galpin: Now get busy and nominate, because
I don't think there's--.
Last time I looked, there was nothing.
>>Ni-Lewis: There was nothing, yeah.
>>Galpin: There was nothing in the categories.
>>Ni-Lewis: Unlike Tower Defense, driving
games is a pretty broad category.
We're not going to kick anything out as long
as it involves driving [something scrapes]
in some ways.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
You don't want just my nominations, because
ultimately, I will just nominate the whole
category.
>>Ni-Lewis: And they will be all about zombies.
>>Meier: To be clear, does that include golf
games?
>>Ni-Lewis: No.
>>Galpin: No.
No.
We are talking about games where you drive
a vehicle.
>>Ni-Lewis: Driving.
>>Galpin: Driving, yeah.
But that is a good point, though.
That is a good point.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
Thank you for clarifying, because we would
have had some embarrassing situations on our
hands, Reto.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
Well, actually, it could have been quite entertaining,
really.
>>Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
So what do you think about something like
Demolition Earth?
Is that a driving game?
There are cars, right?
>>Galpin: Yeah, yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: But you're not driving them, you're
just--
>>Galpin: Well, you know, a game like--.
I think any kind of racing game is really
what we're talking about here, to a large
degree.
But if it has driving as a major mechanic,
we'll consider it.
>>Ni-Lewis: Okay, sounds good.
>>Galpin: Racing would probably be a little
closer.
>>Ni-Lewis: So we're talking about things
like Lane Splitter or the--
>>Galpin: Need for Speed and Asphalt.
>>Ni-Lewis: Need for Speed, Fast and Furious,
that kind of thing.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
So go ahead and nominate your favorites, especially
nominate the favorites that you haven't seen
us feature or that aren't from the big guys.
We'd really love to--
>>Galpin: I consider Grand Theft Auto to be
a driving game.
>>Ni-Lewis: That's true, it is frequently
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So nominate your favorite driving games.
We'll love to take a look at them.
We'll probably take the top five.
We might drop a couple of them out if it's
something that Google Play has featured in
the past or has given a lot of promotion to,
because the intent of this show is to find
the stuff that really hasn't been looked at
as much.
But either way.
Nominate what you want.
And also, when you nominate something, please
include your Google Play ID, or link to your
Google Play profile, because, whereas in the
past, we've had the developers on, now that
anyone can nominate, we actually want to know
why you like the game.
If you'd like to come on the Hangout with
us and talk about why you like a particular
game, if you include your Google+ link, we
will absolutely invite you to the Hangout
and get you on air.
So is that about it?
>>Galpin: That's about it.
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
We'll see you next week when we talk about
driving games.
Thanks for joining us.